first joining us now to react to our top
story tonight author of the bestseller
trumped up the criminalization of
political differences in dangers
democracy Fame Harvard Law Professor
Alan Dershowitz rated the president's
personal attorneys home and his office
and his hotel room Russia collusion has
now become stormy Daniels payment by his
own lawyer well I think actually this
does show us something significant about
the investigation I do think a decision
has been made from the very top that the
Muller investigation is going to stick
to Russia collusion the campaign
obstruction of justice and anything else
relating to Trump's business dealings
any alleged relationships of payments to
women will be given over to the Southern
District of New York now they'll work
together and this may be an attempt to
squeeze Cohen he's the lawyer he's the
guy who knows all the facts about Donald
Trump and to get him to turn against his
client look this is a very dangerous day
today for lawyer client relations I deal
with clients all the time I tell them on
my word of honor that what you tell me
is sacrosanct and now they say just
based on probable cause even though this
was cooperation with Cohen they can
burst into the office grab all the
computers and then give it to another
FBI agent and say you're the firewall we
want you now to read all these
confidential communications tell us
which ones we can get and which ones we
can't get you know if this were the shoe
on the other foot if this were Hillary
Clinton being investigated and they went
into her lawyer's office
the ACLU would be on every television
station in America jumping up and down
the the the deafening silence of the
ACLU and civil libertarians about the
intrusion into the lawyer client
confidentiality is really appalling what
about a Trump sources close to the
President and I saying that this
aggressive this is to squeeze the
president that this is the end of any
negotiations or any chance that
President Trump will ever talk with
Muller and his team of investigators and
more importantly look at the team you
have people that he appointed that have
withheld and been in foul
to a withheld exculpatory evidence in
multiple cases mm-hmm and I want to talk
about that today but one thing first
beef when lawyers think about
cooperating with the prosecutors they
have to know that in exchange for
cooperation they'll get treated decently
and here you have lawyers cooperating
Trump's lawyers cooperated completely
Cohen cooperated completely and what did
they get for it a morning raid on the
office with everything being taken so
this sends a powerful message that
cooperation is not going to be rewarded
by Muller it's not going to be rewarded
by the Southern District and I think the
result may very well be far less
cooperation what would your advice be if
I can ask you if you were talking to the
president tonight I would say all bets
are off that it's clear Muller has a
different agenda I've been arguing this
with different people that I know and my
argument has been is if you are Robert
Muller and you made a comment on a radio
show in New York about the Whitey Bulger
a lot of people in Boston we remember
that very well you remember I'm sure but
four men went to jail he was a Muller
was involved in the case hmm two of them
died in jail they were all later
exonerated over a hundred million dollar
judgment was paid and issues involving
ik SOPA Tory evidence was there but also
his put pit bull Andrew Weissman tens of
thousands of jobs lost because of his
his tactics at Andersen accounting 9'o
decision against him in the Supreme
Court for Merrill executives in jail
that was overturned by the Fifth Circuit
and two examples of him withholding
exculpatory evidence he didn't appoint
Weissman to be a potted plant
he knew his background what does it say
about Muller and his team
well there's Ellis many people think
they're overzealous I don't think
they're partisans here you and I might
disagree I don't think they care whether
they hurt the Democrats or the
Republicans some on the team may I don't
think that's Muller's approach
he is just determined to get his target
and when you appoint somebody to be a
special counsel there's a target on the
back of the president that target on the
back of people close as your laws are
effective I think he has lost
perspective and I think that that
happens when overzealous prosecutors are
and a target and the concern now is that
there won't be cooperation I think we
will now see a scorched-earth policy on
both sides look I don't give a device to
the president except on television if he
wants to listen he can listen but if I
were the president I would at least
seriously consider going to court
tomorrow seeking to have a judge get a
whole of all the lawyer client material
take it away from the prosecutor take it
away from the FBI don't let an FBI agent
look at any of them they've already
judge go through it and have the judge
make a determination as to whether
there's anything in there that's
lawyer-client privilege at this point
though I don't see how the president and
his team could cooperate it's hard it's
hard because they're not getting
anything in return cooperation has to be
a two-way street now the problem of
course for the president is that Muller
ultimately holds the card in which he
can subpoena the president call him in
front of a grand jury without his lawyer
without restrictions and it may be less
worse for the president to make a deal
and sit down and have a for our
conference and president not answer at
that point will plead well he could not
answer certain questions for example if
he's asked why did you fire Comey his
answer he told me well that's one answer
and how was Ron Rosenstein still in the
case the other answer is you cannot
question a president's Article two
decision-making authority just like the
Constitution says you can't question
senators the Supreme Court has said you
can't question judges about their
decisions you can't question a president
about decisions he made that he was
authorized to make on last question if
does this now go on potentially for
years well past the midterms oh there's
no question I think I got to be a fight
ajan how this ends before the midterms
and if it ends just before the midterms
with a report that's condemned natori
the administration imagine the outrage
that will occur if again we see the
Justice Department potentially impacting
and Muller wanted this he set out to do
that when he when he gave this to the to
the Southern District of New York today
that's what his plan was well I think
his plan was to squeeze to try to make
sure he stays within his mandate but
then to use the Southern District to
squeeze Cohen if they can get caught
to become a cooperating witness I doubt
that will ever happen but that's the
tactic prosecutors often use or